une mésaventure folle maintenant est ce
que vous avez à l'hôtel sympa comme
l'attendaient les marins c'est
formidable à une petite nuit à l'hôtel
on se repose on se fait bichonner
sauf que sauf que cette américaine
repérer par les reporters du dimanche
risque de ne plus y retourner
très souvent elle a une mésaventure qui
est américaine qu'il veut pas qu'on la
reconnaisse réclame 100 millions de
dollars à sept au talent et à la chaîne
hilton elle a été filmée nue sous sa
douche à son insu en septembre elle a
reçu un mail avec un lien vers la vidéo
de la douche posté sur un site porno
avec son nom complet dans le titre de la
vidéo j'ai pensé que j'étais foutu dit
elle comme elle ne répond pas le maître
chanteur créer une adresse e-mail avec
le nom de la femme et on voit la vidéo
de la douche à des amis et des collègues
de cette femme
puis ils réclament des milliers de
dollars en bitcoin pour effacer
définitivement la vidéo source
selon son avocat elle ne serait pas la
seule victime bref après ça on ne
prendra plus jamais sa douche heures à
l'hôtel sans y penser c'est assez
terrible alors les faits remonteraient à
juillet 2015
ensuite elle n'a été contacté qu'en
septembre 2018 donc le type après
longtemps quand même pas la vidéo et il
a toujours pas été identifiés ils
réclamaient quand même deux mille
dollars immédiatement
et puis des versements réguliers de 1000
$ par mois heureusement qu'elle est
allée directement porté plainte
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
horrible mais c'est mon pire cauchemar
et en fait j'y pense très sympa tendance
à vous aimer se soumet alors dans des
situations comme celle là parce que dans
sa douche bio par des bandeaux chivot
dit tiens si on le filmait oui bon on
fait pas que cela va se laver dans une
douche ou vers d'autres choses dans une
douche il ya des situations
embarrassantes aller aux toilettes
certaines positions quand on fait
l'amour et tout ça moi parfois gd je
m'arrête même temps
et si quelqu'un si quelqu'un à mon insu
machine est mais je serai comme cette
jeune fille alors déjà je demanderai
mais un paquet de earl et la demande et
j'espère qu'elle les aura parce que
franchement ça crée une série j'avais
pas pensé tout ce que vous m'avez dit
oui et maintenant des mois pour 100
millions de dollars n'y a pas de souci
j'y vais je veux bien l'occasion est
sous la douche je patiente s'était
rassis que ce soit j'aime bien venir
vous allez pour cent mille balles je me
met à poil à cannes pour promouvoir une
conscience de classe où la france
s'apprête à remettre à la mairie on peut
s'interroger aussi sur la façon dont ce
dispositif a été installé ce qu'il y
avait des complicités dans l'eau au sein
de l'hôtel enfin c'est quand même
bizarre de réussira à mettre une caméra
dans une chambre d'hôtel à mon avis cela
dans un hôtel hilton famille de paris
s'il tonne débat est toujours des trucs
chelous dans ces cas là c'est l'habitude
et un peu de monde il est tout ça donc
ça ça choque pas par contre les 100
millions pour la qualité de la vidéo à
la demande beaucoup comme leurs méthodes
attendait elle a quand même été
téléchargée sur plus de dix sites
pornographiques la vidéo de la jeune
femme et si vous imaginez le chien ça va
mal avril du monde la sait pas
sept femmes ont leur hadj oubliée mais
il échouera sa mère à son père dans ce
mail ne vont pas sur le site
pornographique en flandre fait sinon les
gens n'ont alors attendre je vais
justement je vais puisque vous parlez de
famille imaginons votre petite amie ou
votre soeur c'est elle qui se fait
piéger et c'est elle qu'on retrouve sur
dix n'ont même pas dans les hôtels
hilton c'est interdit dans la famille ça
c'est impossible
pornographiques sur tous les sites
pornographiques est tellement le passage
ya tellement de vidéos pour grave
non ça va dingue ce type depuis s'était
pas dites nous ce que vous en pensez
avec le hashtag c'est que des lt il ya
des sujets de débats aujourd'hui à cette
foule